today's guest is a legend in the sport
of hockey and um and a legend just in in
humanity in human history it's a name
that's synonymous uh with being
Victorious he's a four-time Stanley Cup
winner he has more records than um than
Sun Studios this guy has more records in
hockey than anyone you can catch him on
the TNT NHL panel uh I'm so thankful to
spend time with him today Mr Wayne
[Music]
grety I'll sit and tell you my
stories
sh know
me and I will find a song I will sing
[Applause]
it
what's your accent yeah I'm from
Louisiana man it's pretty good we didn't
ever had we had a team I think it was
the algae or something I don't know what
are and was that the East Coast League
probably yeah yeah it was like or the
mud birds or something some team mud
burs yeah it was definitely like even
the mascot sounded like it wasn't going
to survive you know it was like the I
think it was the um that's funny I think
it was a mascot got traded I think it
was the oil spill pigeons or something
like cuz there was we had a lot of
issues down
there that was very funny so I think our
mascot was uh yeah it was bad the mascot
always had bandages on and stuff I
remember they break it was just it
didn't do well no timing probably wasn't
great I it's kind of grown now like
there's a team here in Atlanta that does
pretty well NE like it's like comparable
to double a in baseball mhm not triaa
and they do pretty good here they're and
they're talking about bringing another
NHL team to Atlanta no way be the third
time in 40 years but yeah they tried it
twice I know over the over the over the
history of time and do you know like
yeah why doesn't it succeed you think in
certain markets is it just not the is it
well does it just take people to be
there or does it take something special
to be in a market for hockey to survive
it's a little bit of both because we
don't have you know we don't have um
like baseball and football it's been in
the south in the southwest forever right
oh yeah hockey's just kind of getting
there so back in the 70s when the Flames
first came in the expansion rules were
different the owners wanted the money
the league wanted the money but they
gave you the worst teams so they would
go five six seven years and go well it's
not a hockey City well people get tired
of paying to watch a team lose right
yeah so then they came back again it was
kind of the same expansion rules and it
failed
again the everybody got wiser and when
Vegas came in they got the ninth best
player on every team they got low draft
picks and they built the foundation and
people got excited look our team's good
Seattle got the same sort of thing as
Atlant or as Vegas if Atlanta gets
another team they're going to get that
Advantage again of getting yeah they're
going to get good treatment and maybe
this will become a good hockey City cuz
people are saying Jesus we're winning
and let's go to the games yeah so it's
not fair to people of Atlanta their
teams were so bad you just say I'm not
paying anymore yeah at a certain point
you can't yeah you can't go and be
really supporting some of the teams I
think in the South well the south is
also kind of religious there's more
religion there you know and the only
person we've ever seen even kind of or
the only person that people believe like
behaves like or gets Wild on water is
the Jesus really so I think the second
you see a guy saying hey look what I'm
going to do out here on this frozen lake
I think it makes you wonder what's going
on here well in Canada we call our
Arenas churches oh yeah because you know
in Canada it's hockey and religion those
are the two biggest things right so you
can be you know Sports is very popular
in our country football Canadian
football baseball the Blue Jays do well
the Raptors have done really well so
it's kind of Canada's team the Raptors
and the Blue Jays yeah but is everywhere
right so you can be driving in your car
in July and if you're listening to talk
radio it's still 90% hockey that they're
talking about June July and August
because you can still do it and it's so
popular right oh yeah people love it
people I think it's unbelievable yeah
it's you know like down down in the US I
always encourage parents to tell their
kids play every sport tennis baseball
football basketball soccer uh field
lacrosse and they're all big and if you
sat down here you would say Okay
baseball is probably the most popular
sport or no it's basketball is the
biggest sport yeah and then you're like
well football's pretty big but in Canada
there's no definition it's one it's ice
hocke it's hockey that's it yeah I think
I'm trying to think of why we
never yeah I think yeah up there if
everything's frozen you you
know yeah well we got a big Advantage
because you got free ice yeah you got
free ice you know it's a big thing you
know yeah ice is I think $18 a bag run
from yeah it it's it's ice is expensive
and you know parents a lot of parents
it's hard for them to afford hockey
equipment ice skates uh paying for ice
time but in Canada most of the places
you can play I grew up in Southern
Ontario which is uh basically between
Niagara Falls New York and uh Detroit oh
yeah that's I mean that's a third self
for the freezer section buddy that's it
gets pretty chill
so we had an nice rink in my backyard
from the time I was saw I saw some lore
about that so my dad would go and he
would buy a sprinkler head in December
which they always thought he was
crazy who's buying a sprinkler head
Christmas time anyway and he would put
it out in the middle of the ice and he
would let it go back and forth for like
two hours and then go move it another
part of the ice and his ice was always
about this thick and it would last till
probably the end of March
did he lay a good rank oh he had the
best really yeah and he was funny people
used to stop by the house and say how
does Walter get his grass so green what
do you do what are you putting in your
grass my dad didn't do anything it was
just probably from the ice being so good
for the the grass he always had the
greenest grass in in the neighborhood
and didn't do
anything that's pretty classic man yeah
we had some uneven areas I remember I
played baseball I mean I I don't know if
I was you know Mom signed me up a couple
Seasons man and it wasn't great for me
but um our field was uneven we had an
uneven field so every ball if you hit
anything second base it was all ended up
in right field right we probably had 25%
gradient on the field so we had at least
two right fielders always at least well
that's probably now listen I grew up
loving baseball I went saw my grandson
play the other day he had his hat on
backwards I think he was picking Danny L
always yeah oh yeah there's always that
kid out there who ends up doing being a
gardener or something yeah and then I
took him to we went to watch him play
Ice Hockey the next day and they're out
there sweating and skating for an hour
loving it yeah and they got to figure
out a way to get these kids more
enthusiastic about baseball because it's
not a lot of fun for some of them who
are standing out in the Outfield yeah I
think and I think that's one of the
reasons may I don't know if baseball is
I guess it's always America sport
because there's something rooted in
Tradition about it there's something I
mean you give an American a hot dog
they'll sit there and do anything for a
little while you know but I think it's
true yeah it's and I you know I do it if
somebody's like and the history of the
game you know the history of baseball
from bab Ruth what he did to what Jackie
Robinson did for everyone there's so
much history and let's face it it's
economically easier to buy a pair of
shoes and a baseball glove than to have
to buy a whole entire hockey equipment
sort of yeah to set that up in certain
parts right and then in other
the other way you like it would be
tougher to like heat a basketball court
in the winter in Canada so that people
have the opportunity to be there and
play as much you yeah we we don't you
know although the Raptors have really
found a niche in our country like
they're huge yeah people love them I was
in your country when they won the
championship and I wasn't in Vancouver
but people were like beating each other
and hugging each other at the same time
so like in our country like you're in
Vancouver you're Canucks fan and you're
in Alberta you either Flames Oilers and
all the way across right but if you're
in Vancouver or New Finland you're a
blue jay's fan or a Raptor's fan it's
just it's Canada's team and they just
all cling to it it's something pretty
special about it and I always see when
guys get traded up they're more
basketball than baseball and guys well I
don't want to play in Canada I want to
stay in my own country but the guys who
go there will tell you they get treated
phenomenally it's a great city to live
in it's a great country and people are
nice oh okay people's always so nice in
Canada even if somebody was angry they
may I bet they would they'd come across
the street and theyd just say hey I'm
angry but but I'm sorry yeah you know a
lot of stories up there they're just too
kind well I noticed even like you know I
grew up in the South there's a lot of
like I don't know if there's still as
much but especially when I was growing
up there was like more racial disparity
down there you know cuz there's a lot of
history of like black and white racism
down there and um and when I was in
Canada I don't feel that energy I I
don't everybody seems the same it's like
say that to people that we just we don't
seem to have racism in our country
people all seem to get along you know
and
it's that's why people always come up to
and they say you're from Canada right
and I say yeah they're like Canadians
are all so nice and I go yeah I think
they are and I said but you know I got
five American Kids five American
grandchildren and they're all nice kids
too so you can meet a lot of nice people
in the United States right yeah well I
think if you're coming out of that
Gretzky lineage I think you guys have to
see you guys I mean it seem pretty just
like nice folks you know um well they
had a they had a good mother so yeah you
know listen when you're when you're
working and playing hockey you know it's
hard you know the schedule's tough oh
yeah you especially playing on the west
coast in LA and Edmonton we're always
either playing or in an airplane right
so listen uh I love my kids dearly but
it was the mother who was around them
the mothers are so so vital it's like my
my relationship with my mom and dad was
very close my dad was sort of this
hockey father of the country you know
people loved my dad yeah Walter grety
man but I would always say but it was my
mom behind the scenes that kept her
family she was a wonderful lady and she
always kind of stayed out of the
Limelight like when I was a kid and I'd
play all the parents used to sit sort of
together and my mom would sit in the
corner by
herself so what did she like to do your
mom like what were some like when she
had time for herself what were some
hobbies that she liked cuz I I mean from
what it hear from what it sounds like
your dad probably got pretty involved
with you once you started playing hockey
as much so a lot of people don't know
this but I had a um Down syndrome aunt
and she was born in the ' 50s and back
in those days they would take these kids
and basically they put them in asylums
and medicate them
and people yeah people didn't know what
to do so my grandmother said you know
I'm not sending her to school so she
never went to school a day in her life
um she was was by the end she was a
little bit blind she lived till she was
63 and my grandfather was from uh Russia
bellarus Minsk Russia my grandmother was
from uh
Ukraine and the kids were born in Canada
and my grandfather would speak to her in
Russian my grandmother would speak to
her in Ukrainian and we all communicated
with her in English oh and that'll give
anybody down syndrome I feel like and my
dad used to always say if you don't
believe in the good Lord there's a great
example right here but so when she was
Tri then she could understand but she
spoke only English and if you didn't
know her you'd have a a hard time
understanding her but we grew up with
her so we were fine so when my
grandmother was passing she said do me
one favor don't put her in her home and
of course my mother said I'll take care
of her so she lived with my parents for
at least 12 years I guess and then um uh
wow yeah and then you were a child too
it was when you were a kid no she so my
grandmother would have passed in 88
um and that's when she moved in with my
mom and dad so she had her hands full
with her own kids grandkids my U my aunt
um if she her enjoyment really was uh
Friday nights going with her her mom who
was my grandmother they go they love
Bingo that was a big thing in our
hometown and she could my dad said she
could play Bingo every night she loved
it that much and I used to did how'd you
do today I want $7 I'm like okay at
least you're
winning so her her life was around our
kids and the grandkids but her enjoyment
was going to Bingo wow so she was kind
of she just found a lot of joy in her
family and then some simple pleas sounds
like just Simple Pleasures kind of she
was very simple like she was um I'll
tell you when I turned Pro um I said to
my parents I'm going to buy you a house
and my mom and dad said we don't need a
house we we're we're fine right here and
and I so there was a little piece of
property was an acre just down the
street from where where I grew up and
where they were living so I went and
bought it secretly and I took them over
there and my mom said what are you doing
I said well I'm going to build you this
house here you're going to something
really special she goes no no my house
is fine she goes but if you want to do
something you can put a pool in her
backyard I put a pool in the backyard
sold my piece of property cuz they
didn't want to move into it and she and
they lived there to the very end and
when my dad passed recently I bought the
house and so now it's I own my house oh
yeah I was going to ask actually where
what that was like so your mom was like
now that all that skating's done I want
to I want to pool back here yeah oh yeah
she said your your father's not building
a hockey rink anymore I want a swimming
pool she loved having the swimming pool
in the backyard there is something nice
about it isn't it yeah and she loved the
barbecue I was telling the story you
know now they have everything so
regimented right so back in in back in
when you win the Stanley Cup they have
these two guys that travel with the
trophy cuz it's so special like they
don't want anything to happen to it and
they don't want it to break and so they
keep a good eye on it right like kind of
like a like a n like a little bit of
like a um like um little um gargoyles
kind of but like like yeah they just
protector whatever yeah they just watch
it they travel with it like Hitman or
whatever yeah oh my mom got pissed if we
got buy her nice dishes she would get
yeah so there they are days um when I
when I won a championship I remember one
day was the summertime I was at my folks
house my mom was doing a barbecue my
both grandmothers were there and I'm
sitting there and I said to my dad gez I
should just I should get the Stanley Cup
here and get some pictures so I called
the Hall of Fame and I said hey I'm
having a barbecue this afternoon can you
guys drive down the Stanley Cup and they
said yeah yeah we'll be down in an hour
they got in the car put the cup in drove
down gave me the cup we took pictures in
the backyard Y and then they took the
cup back to the Hall of Fame now it's
all organized right now each guy gets a
day with the cup it's all organized and
the guy's travel with the trophy but
back then was just like hey uh can I
have the cup this afternoon they say
yeah no problem bring the cup down yeah
so some of the best pictures I have with
my grandmother my mom my dad in the
backyard just holding the Stanley Cup
yeah plate of beans in one hand and the
Stanley Cup in the other corn oh yeah
that was big huh yeah oh wow yeah I can
only have so much corn and then I wish I
had some beans usually um yeah dude
you're like a ice Master do you ever
realiz like you kind of mastered like a
or anyway to me it seems like you know
like do you ever go to like are you ever
at like Disney on Ice you ever take your
kids to Disney On Ice and you're just
like yell you know you're like those
Chipmunks are off sides you know like
like do you have that much of a or when
you see an ice maker on a fridge you
just growl at it I feel like you just
have that no that you're a frozen water
master I will tell you this so I said to
somebody the other day we were on a lake
and they said you want to jump in and it
was kind of a cold day I said you know
I'm way better when that water's frozen
I'm not going in but I did go to Disney
On Ice one time because my friend and
and neighbor Scotty Hamilton I went to
see the show one time Scotty Hamilton
he's a dancer he was a yeah he was an
Olympic gold medalist he's Olympic gold
medalist yeah and then he F skater yeah
figure skater so he was really
phenomenal figure skater and one is
right there yeah wonderful guy so I
think it was at either Disney on Ice or
one of those shows and we went to see it
and we sat down by the ice and I think
the time Kar vit was in it oh yeah
yeah it was pretty phenomenal like what
they can do it's so different than ice
skating like I think there's a lot of
figure skaters that could transfer to
ice skating but I don't think there's a
lot of ice skaters that could put on
figure skates and do well it's a whole
different thing they're so athletic I
live with a guy for like probably four
months and he was uh I don't know what
he was he was pretty tall but he would
he was a figure skater and he took us
outside one time they had a Volkswagen
Rabbit outside and he ran and jumped
over it from one side to the other side
that's pretty amazing it was just
unbelievable and it was just an
afternoon yeah it was just like it just
blew my mind man well they're they you
know the training and the techniques
that they have because they have to do
those turns and they have to get high in
the air to be able to do a triple so
they probably in the off season they
probably do a lot of squat training you
know so that when they do get on the ice
that they're they're much it's much
easier yeah but yeah they're really they
get out there yeah those guys can really
can do it I think ice skating is pretty
incredible yeah I think we just missed
being in the southern part of the us we
miss all of the lacrosse we miss all of
the you know the sports really the the
the the uh whatever it's called the
difference of sports just changes over
you know as you go down south but you
know um I was talking earlier about how
popular hockey is and it's definitely
huge in our country but if you were to
go around anywhere and interview people
outside of Canada and say what is the
national sport of Canada they' all say
ice hockey or 90% of them but it's
lacrosse but it's actually lacrosse
lacrosse was invented in Six Nations
Reserve which is just outside of my
hometown of Branford so a couple things
we're very proud of Alexander green bell
his first phone call from Branford my
hometown did he really yes who' he call
he called somebody in Paris Ontario
which was like a 15 minutes away 15
miles away probably a chick I
bet who you going to call if you get
your first call you're going to call
probably some woman you or you know some
lady you might want to say you know so
they actually have the telephone I don't
know in in in Branford no yeah and uh
the other thing is were very proud of
was that lacrosse was invented in in
Canada it was it was a great sport yeah
dude I didn't I even know about can I
mean I didn't even when I was growing up
we didn't even really believe in Canada
you know listen I I will tell you this
in Canada and I don't mean this to be
controversial we learn growing up the
geography of pretty much the world but a
lot of Canada in the United States when
American Kids kind of grow up they
didn't learn a whole lot about Canada
that there's provinces like a lot of
Canadian kids can name every state in
every Capital but there's only a handful
of people I know that can name all the
provinces probably 70 people that in
America I'm not even joking I remember
in our school we learned about America
right some kids can barely do that but
then above it on the map they had a
picture of a it was like a wolf chasing
a boy you know and that was and we're
like what is that and they're like
that's that you know that's Canada one
of the one of the first things I learned
was the capital of Louisiana Baton Rouge
oh yeah I always remember that I don't
know why I remember that but I did it's
a pretty good place they had a hockey
team for a little while didn't do well
but I think hockey's going to start
going back there now you watch cuz
people are the greatest thing about our
sport are the people who are in the game
like oetkin and Crosby and McDavid and
Matthews and some of the Bruins too yeah
they're they're just good good kids you
know like they understand like they're
hardworking and they they love they're
unselfish to their teams but they're
unreal for the league and in their
communities like these kids are good
kids so our sport is growing expanding
all the time and more and more kids are
playing hockey in Arizona Texas
Louisiana Florida so Nevada Nevada's a
hot bed right now because the they the
hockey team done so well yeah people it
gets infectuous yeah and everybody loves
it yeah so I think more and more kids
will start playing hockey and I see our
game just growing all the time um what
was was there a part of the game that
you like did you ever play goalie like
because every time I see clips of you
and everything you're always not playing
goalie right which is fine if I was a
goalie I'd be more like playing
dodgeball right getting out of the way
but did you ever did you ever do it to
uh to learn about what it was like like
did you ever like um the only time I
ever did it was when I was a kid we
played ball hockey M ball hockey played
with the tennis ball and running shoes
Okay un like a sport court or gymnasium
and so the only time I would play goal
where I wasn't scared to get hit by a
puck it was a tennis ball every now and
then I play goal but I was
listen people used to ask me do you ever
block a shot and first of all do you
know how hard that puck is and for the
average hockey fan they don't realize
those pucks are every Puck is frozen so
the pucks that you're using not only
hurt but they're frozen too man who
froze them so they're in the referee's
box and so they're fro Patriots probably
did it Frozen so they don't bounce so
they so it doesn't bounce really because
it's made out of what rubber rubber yeah
so oh my God and so they used to sayt do
you ever block a shot and I said why
would I that's how why they pay the
goalie that's not my job I don't ask him
to score goals he doesn't need to ask me
to block shots I kind of faked that you
like think you're in the lane but the
guy had a lot of room to shoot around
you you know when I started podcasting
and online store was probably one of the
furthest things from my imagination or
my mind you know um but over time we've
created one and and it's been super easy
thanks to Shopify Shopify is the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
any and every stage of your business
from the launch your online shop stage
to the first real life store stage all
the way to the did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is there to help
you you grow Shopify helps you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout up to 36%
better compared to other leading
Commerce platforms sign up for a $1 per
month trial period at shopify.com
Theo all lowercase that's right go to
shopify.com
tho lowercase now to grow your business
no matter what stage you're in
shopify.com
com/ Theo cold turkey may be great on
sandwiches but there's a better way to
break your bad habits we're not talking
about some weird mind voodoo from your
crazy neighbor or them or them trying to
do a seance on the mailman or something
we're talking about
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that instead of
vapor fume uses flavored Air instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
start the holidays off right with the
good habit by going to trf nume.com
Theo that's trifu
m.com tho and getting the journey packed
today fume is giving listeners of the
show 20% off until December 1st when
they use my code Theo to help make
starting the good habit that much easier
trif nume.com
Theo Mary ballus from our friends over
at manscaped you know manscape keeps
your body hairfree you can dehare
yourself you know unless you want to
keep some sideburns on that Wang homie
you feel me the holidays are approaching
but what if I told you that the
celebrations are starting early this
year that's because the perfect gift
does exist
exist that's right manscapes brand new
performance package 5.0 Ultra featuring
the new lawnmower 5.0 watch all your
wishes and mistletoe kisses come true
included in this special package is the
lawnmower 5.0 Ultra the weed whacker 2.0
ears and nose trimmer manscapes liquid
formulations and two free gifts get 20%
off in free shipping with code theom
manscaped.com
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code
tho manscaped get your jingle balls
ready for the holidays was there a um
you had so many records man was there
something that you felt like you wanted
to get that you couldn't get kind of was
there or were you even keeping tabs on
that kind of
stuff yeah I didn't really keep tabs on
it um I never I did when I retired I
knew it was time to retire and I didn't
think back and say gosh I wish I would
have done this or accomplished
this but I did I did look back and say
okay cuz people ask me what is your
favorite record and they're all they're
all fun they're all you know I'm proud
of them all but I got my favorite record
is the year I scored 50 goals in 39
games and for me it's my favorite record
your third season or something yeah and
and that's my favorite record because
listen all records are made to be broken
but to me that's going to be the hardest
record to break to get 50 goals in 38
games so from that point of view is my
favorite you seem like the kind of guy
that if somebody broke it you would even
be you would applaud the fact that they
did that well yeah you know listen I
learned from two of the best people in
the world my dad who was a wonderful man
and Gordy how and Gordy how was my idol
when you when you're when you're a kid
and you have an idol a lot of times you
meet them and you go W it was just okay
maybe that guy had a bad day or whatever
and you go well I met Gordy how when I
was 10 and my dad said to me how was
meeting Gordy how and I said I I can't
believe it he goes what I said he was
bigger better and nicer than I ever
imagined in my little brain at 10 years
old you know and so when I was breaking
records Gordy how was always there he
was the first guy to shake my hand and
give me a hug and so you know oetkin is
going to break my record uh which is
going to be great for our game and when
he does I'll be there for him I hope I'm
I'm on the ice and I hope I get to be
one of the first people to congratulate
him
uh because it's a it's it's a special
record and he it's good for a game if he
does break it
yeah um oh that's him right there it was
so exciting cuz I got the afternoon off
school and I got a new suit that morning
so it was a big day oh yeah dude look at
you know who you look you know who you
look like a little bit who's that you
know who I'm going to say or no no no
idea Princess Diana a
[Laughter]
little just the fact that she's a female
I don't know if that that's a compliment
not and I just mean look man and the I
think it's very much com she was a tough
lady heard I've heard it before yeah you
have yeah yeah man I thinkk God every
now and then when my hair is a little
whatever some guys see guys should got
Rod Stewart hair oh I think there's I
bet a couple of men played on your team
just because they wanted to be near you
B but no Gordy Gordy was so nice he was
just so it was a dinner it was a charity
dinner this is an incredible story uhhuh
and 700 people at the dinner and that
was the year I scored 400 goals so the
city wanted me to be part of it and you
know when you're 10 years old you can't
even stand up and do a speech in front
of your classmates right so they had
told the guy so you're only 10 at this
time yeah so they had told the MC Wayne
just introduced him he's not going to
talk and so um Joe thyman was
there yeah Gordy how when you were 10
yeah Sandy Holly a famous jockey and so
they all get up and they kind of talk
for seven or eight minutes and people
laugh and G go so the guy announces my
name and I'm like oh no and I'm already
Frozen and Gordy says to me now listen
when you go up there just tell them
you're lost about your skates and your
hockey stick and so I got okay okay so I
got up there and I was shaking and I I
remember I said Thank you and I started
balling I got a standing ovation I went
and sat down so years later I called a
friend of mine called me and he said
Gordy's hometown of Saskatoon they're
doing this Charity Dinner which like a
Lion's Club which was very similar to
the one I did in my hometown mhm yeah we
had Lion's Club in our town too yeah so
I called Gordy and his son Mark and I
said listen Gordy came to my hometown
when I was 10 I really like Gordy to
come with me to Saskatoon and I want to
surprise everybody so we were in
Saskatoon this dinner and they sold I
think there was about 3,000 people there
and the prime minister of Canada
happened to be in town and he go he
called me and he say is it okay if I
come over there and sort of MC this and
ask a few questions for the people and I
said absolutely no problem at all so I
said oh by the way uh nobody knows this
but I flew Gordy in he's at the hotel
and gord's going to come tonight and
we're going to introduce him well it was
like I wasn't there anymore the Prime
Minister was like okay maybe somebody
will do do you and I'll do Gord so
anyway when I got up on stage I said to
everybody uh I got a great surprise he I
met him in my Hometown I I figured I
should come to his hometown and Gordy
how came out and I swear to God if
people didn't stop clapping they'd still
be clapping today because it was the
most it was the longest nicest Standing
Ovation that I've ever seen somebody get
and he so was so genuinely loved and he
he was such he was a really people don't
realize this Gordy how is a dirty player
first time I play against him I took the
puck from him and next thing I know I
got a whack I was 17 years old and he
cracked my thumb he said don't ever take
the puck from me again I said okay never
going to happen again yeah anyway so he
got such an evasion and after the event
we went back to the hotel and Gordy had
brought back a couple of his buddies
that he knew they he hadn't seen in a
while a couple older gentlemen and we
just sat around and he he had a he
remember he sat there and he had a cold
beer and he said this was one of the
greatest days greatest nights of my life
so it was very cool when you when you
look at like
um like when you were a kid was most of
your relationship with your dad like
hockey like was it tough to cuz if you
became like if you excelled at something
early right and a lot of times Fathers
and Sons will it's tough for Fathers and
Sons to find like a common ground
sometimes to connect on on things you
know parents are always putting their
kids into different things and and dads
are always trying to connect with their
children you know was there other ways
that you could like was that most of
y'all's relationship like I'm just kind
of like like I guess I'm curious like
what it was like we had a normal
relationship like normal fatherson um he
was both parents tremendously supportive
um you know by the time I was 10 11 12
years old I was playing in arenas that
were selling out that's crazy you like a
circuses in town a little bit and I not
like that but I you mean but in those
days too it was such a big world because
there was no internet there was no cell
phones and so yeah a kid might be 3
hours
away and you would hear about him and
then when you play against him my dad
would be in the car and after the game
he would say to me his favorite line was
always no matter how good you think you
are there's somebody out there better
than you and I'd say okay and even when
I was 15 16 when people said okay he's
going to be a professional hockey player
my dad never one time said you know oh
he's a can't miss or he's going to make
it I mean he hoped cuz he knew how much
I loved it but he never pressured me the
only thing he pressured me about is he
would call me say you didn't miss any
classes today so oh yeah he I said dad I
don't miss class because if I miss class
the team so I was playing Junior Hockey
and it was hard cuz we practice every
day and we travel a lot yeah and so they
were the team was always on you like you
better be in class so he was more
concerned that I was in class I remember
I was uh 17 and I had this uh school
teacher and he it was I was taking a
physics class and I hated physics and
chemistry was I kept thinking now where
is this going to where am I going to use
this in the world yeah that's all I kept
thinking um anyway and he said if you
just put the work in I'll pass you so I
did I went to class I went to an extra
class every day with him and he worked
an extra half hour every day he passed
me and that was the year that month I
got offered to turn pro and I signed a
pro contract and I remember I came back
and I I bought him a gift it wasn't a
whole it wasn't a big thing it was like
a briefcase or something thanking him
for not for being so patient with me and
being so nice to me he was so grateful
and it was always sort of when I signed
my dad said you're going to stay Pro
Hockey you're going to stay in high
school till you're 18 I don't care what
you do but you're going to school till
your 18 so here I am playing pro hockey
and going to high school I was picking
up my teammate's daughter we were in the
same class no way the guy's name was Jim
neelson and I would pick his daughter up
we were in the same school same class
then I go to practice you were like ice
V Presley so the principal called me in
one day and he said son I don't know
you're not going to amount to anything
you're missing too many classes and I'm
like well and he said you know I should
just kick you out and I said listen it
was like early January and I said listen
do me a favor and he goes what I said
give me till January 26th and if if I
haven't changed my ACT by then you can
kick me out but I knew I couldn't go to
class cuz we're always traveling and
playing I was playing pro hockey playing
in Quebec City and going to Cincinnati
and you have an ego were you in were you
like the fwn at this point in class I I
sat in the back corner I just minded my
own business so the day I turned 18 I
walked into the principal and I said I
just want to thank you for not K kicking
me out but I quit I'm done and I quit
school and my I said I called my dad and
and my dad said well you promise me stay
at 18 cuz the contract wasn't valid
unless he would sign it un your father
would sign it cuz I wasn't 18 yet and so
he said I'll sign it but you got to stay
in high school so did you ever finish
High School technically um no but I'm a
doctor
yeah does that mean anything I'm an
honorary doctor um hey it counts to me
bro so you get most of the 12 grades I
think that's a lot people are always
like you got to do all of them yeah um I
always yeah you know what I I I'm an
honorary doctor it's funny I I did the
commencement speech for I said okay I'm
going to pick one and people have been
kind enough to offer me and I said you
know what I'm going to do one and so I
picked the University of Alberta which
is in Emon which I thought was fitting
and I have it's so funny cuz I have
different nicknames so in the hockey
world they call me Gratz graty great one
no just
grats and in the golf world they call me
cuz I was telling the guys one day was
playing with I think it was Dustin and
Jordan spe and I said you know I'm a
doctor something to that effect so the
golf world calls me Doc and the hockey
world calls me gretz do you you ever get
to play with Sheldon Sor you know
Sheldon I play a lot with them we're
next to neighbors oh that's awesome
Sheldon's a friend of mine he's just
going to have a baby right now yeah
that's so exciting no he's unreal guy U
he's a beautiful guy like I'm not saying
he's beautiful but somebody said it I
said yeah he's got a big heart he's got
a huge heart he's so mellow Sheldon's
not going to have a heart attack like
he's always mellow he's always happy
he's never upset a very calm person um
yeah he's one him and his wife are great
people yeah he's handsome dude I think
that's the weird thing about some oh
yeah he's violently handsome you're like
damn that dude's handsome and then he
hits you yeah and that's why I always
say to people I looked at guys like him
and that's why I retired they're soig
they're so and today these guys are so
big today and the equipment is so much
better and the skates are so much better
and the teaching that they get at a
younger age is so much better these guys
are incredible athletes and I'm I'm glad
I played when I played I'm glad I'm gone
now yeah yeah sometimes it's like you
fit in time in a certain space you know
I was yeah time means everything I know
yeah you would know man I got lucky you
know listen um I came in at the right
time
I I came in when I came in they had a a
a wh which was similar to Aba AFL and
they were signing kids under 20 which
seems illegal in some place I mean it's
like how well so I signed but had there
not been that League I might have had to
play another three years a junior you
never know if you get hurt I may never
have made it right so my timing was
really fortunate really lucky do you
like to read any books are you reading
anything I'm reading one right now uh
Albert everything I do is sports related
oh yeah you love it that much huh so
I'll give you an example when I was 15
years old I was playing on a junior
hockey team M and it was so exciting
because my one of my teammates was
Murray how who was Gordy how's youngest
son oh wow and he's just a wonderful kid
and I wore number nine that year cuz I
always loved Gordy and so when he came
in I said look you should wear number
nine your dad's Gordy House s my number
of and he goes no no no no this is Wayne
this is my last year of hockey um I'm
going to enjoy it and I go okay he goes
I'm going to be a doctor he was a really
intelligent guy and he did go on to
become a doctor so we get on the team
bus and we travel to the
city he he'd get on there and he'd have
all these books right and I'd get on no
books and he goes Wayne you got you got
to get your education you gotta I I'm
going to a hockey game I can't think
about reading right now and doing
homework
and so about two weeks later I got on
the bus and I had like five or six books
I sit down beside him and he he goes
good to see your taking notes Here Wayne
that's good good for you and he said he
goes what do you got geography history I
go well I got Gordo hockey my way Gordo
hockey tips I said you want to be a doct
Christmas you want to be a doctor I want
to be a hockey player but he went on to
be a a tremendous doctor and he actually
gave the eulog for his dad's funeral
when he when Gordy passed away which was
pretty
remarkable um do you did you speak at
your dad's funeral what was that like
yeah I did I spoke both at my mom and my
dad's um and sorry to hear yeah sorry
about your folk yeah it
was you know what it was funny cuz
there's something that just takes over
inside you that you get through it right
like I remember my mom passed my dad
called me and said you know we you speak
and I said of course so when my dad was
passing my brothers and my sister said
you know will you speak and I said yeah
the ironic thing was when my dad passed
we were still in the midst of the
pandemic so it was actually in a lot of
ways it was nice for our family cuz
there was only 22 of us there and you
know cuz you couldn't you couldn't
invite everybody had it had it not been
at that time he probably would have had
to get buried or had the funeral in a in
a hockey arena with so many people he's
so he was so loved by so many people so
when I I found both times sitting there
going oh this is going to be hard and
when I got up there it just kind of
flowed because my dad when I spoke at
his he was so religious my dad and you
know he never missed Church on a Sunday
when every Sunday and he used to tease
the kids because he tried out for the
church choir and they wouldn't let him
in it
come on yeah so there was a little boy
across the
street disabled and blind and my dad
picked him up every morning at 10: a.m.
every Sunday morning at 10:00 a.m. and
took him to church every Sunday and then
brought him back home he taken
McDonald's and then back home and he did
it every Sunday so when my dad was
passing he's so religious but I remember
he was still fighting to stay down here
so to speak um he was 22 days and know
basically on a deathbed right and U the
minister would come every night at our
house and he would give him his lost
rights and I said yeah I say to minister
my dad's got the biggest heart you're
coming I'll see you
tomorrow so anyway when when we did give
the uh when I did give the US I could
feel like he was there and he he got me
through it wow that's fascinating man
yeah I remember I went to my dad's
feeling it was like I don't know it's
just such a Str it's such
a I don't know it's wild seeing
something like that happen I think do
you think it helped that your father had
such a faith did he give you so like a
oh yeah yeah like he knew there was life
after death he was going to see his
mother he's going to see his father so
probably part of him was probably
excited huh yeah I
think yeah in some ways but I think he
wanted to be here as long as he could he
loved being around his grandkids he
loved being around people um he was just
really special in that sense um you know
I don't not too often you can say that
people don't have enemies but I don't
think my dad had an enemy like he was
beloved by everyone um I remember one
time I came home when I when I would go
home and visit him every now and then
you know my dad would tell the whole
city right you were coming yeah so I got
smart on that I I I call my mom and I
said I'll be home tomorrow don't tell
Dad so I get there in the morning this
is hilarious and I walk in and there's a
guy lying on the couch oh yeah I get
over to my mom and I kind of know
everybody that goes in and out of our
house you know my mom was in the kitchen
and I said who's lying on the couch who
is that she goes I don't know um but
he's hitchiking across the country from
Newland wanted to see the house so your
dad told him to spend the night and have
a good
meal so that's the kind of guy my dad
was and the guy spent the night and got
up in the morning and him and I had
coffee at the dining room table way got
to get a picture with my jersey on when
I happened to be home that day and he
was hitchiking rest of Canada that was
the kind of dad my dad was wow they
should put a they should put him in a
jersey and let's let him hitchhike the
country forever and just make it like a
thing you know yeah well you know it's
not the Stanley Cup but hey guys have
you met Stanley and everybody just picks
him up there you go yeah be funny um I'm
trying to think about something else
that's pretty neat man do you
uh well we talk about my wife's family
they my mother-in-law's 102 no way which
is amazing yall got that long blood in
you homie she she's 102 she's a great
lady she lived with us helped raise our
kids for 30 years um but she lives in
our house in St Louis and when we're
there she likes to go for lunch or
dinner almost every day and she gets
around on her own it's truly remarkable
and what's amazing is that unfortunately
her her dad passed away at 56 uh which
is awful cancer and two sisters who had
breast cancer both passed away and the
mom was 102 and still going strong wow
that's incredible you got some longevity
then in your uh jeans huh my my dad
always said it's the hours you get
before midnight for sleeping for
sleeping oh God gives you longevity and
my mother-in-law is asleep by 8:30 and
gets up at 4:00 I think there's
something to that I think there's
something to it there's something nice
when you're up in the morning and you
feel like you like just kind of got up
with the sun you just feel like you're
kind of dialed in you know it's amazing
the older you get the earlier you get up
right and the less you sleep for some
reason yeah a that weird man and my dad
used to always say I remember he had a
famous quote to me he goes uh you know
you spend your whole life as a kid
trying to figure out how to stay at a
bed and as an adult you try to figure
out your whole life how do I get to
sleep how do I get in bed it's so true
yeah yeah I think sometimes when people
are like sometimes if I even think about
like leaving this Earth You know and
passing away from here I think about
just getting some good rest you know
it's kind of the way I think about it in
my head it's like you know some of that
will be relieving did you guys ever go
any vacations and stuff when you were a
kid cuz if you always doing hockey it
seemed like you probably always on the
run did youall ever go to Florida or
somewhere the North
Pole that's funny North Pole um well two
things are are my mom's life and this is
sometimes she would complain about this
U so in the winter time it was hockey
tournaments summertime was aome baseball
tournaments so that was our vacations
and then every 3 years my dad's
sister uh cuz my parents grandparents in
the ' 50s had tobacco farms and people
from the South would come up to work in
the summer cuz the the season for
picking is a little different so they
can make money in Canada then go back oh
that's nice so my uncle was from
Greensboro Carolina he married my dad's
sister and every two years we would go
down there for two weeks we drive down
for 2 weeks um and and and um stay there
with our cousins and my aunt and uncle
and that was probably our vacation right
uh I remember one time driving back I
convinced my parents to stop in Cooper
toown which was a little out of the way
and my mom was so mad she said we spent
an extra six hours drying so you could
go to Cooper town and my dad would say
this is good for him it's
okay oh that's so much fun man I love
even when you were talking about like
the lore like back in the day if you had
like if you heard a kid playing you'd
have to go and see him like oh yeah yeah
that was the way it was back then oh
there was something so much more magical
about like lore like they don't have as
much of it anymore because everybody you
know everybody I don't know but you know
the funny thing is like if you say to
kids
today like New York to London England's
not that far we used to think Branford
to Windsor Ontario which was a 2 and 1
half hour drive was like going to the
other other side of the world right like
the world was so much bigger back then
oh we thought Florida if we saw somebody
had a shirt on in Louisiana if said
Florida on it it was like You' been
there was only two places to go must be
the richest guy here yeah heaven and
Florida here you go yeah like dang
you've been to Florida we we never got
to Florida uh but we got to Carolina
which was really nice it was great going
with our relatives that was and when you
guys just all get in the car and just
drive down there yeah we had a um old
car a station wagon um and where would
you sit I was always uh in the back seat
yeah you know and then it's like school
huh yeah and we would drive and gosh we
didn't have air conditioning in our car
so every now and then you roll down the
window so it wasn't as hot U but then
you get down to Carolina it was so humid
right you be like oh put the windows up
and let's sweat um so I my dad used to
always tease me when I was 14 13 14 15
he'd always say if you do make
professional hockey just remember by I
just buy be a Cadillac yeah so I bought
one of those big for its Cadillac I
brought it home right so the summer goes
by the year goes by I go back home the
next summer and I look at the car and
there's like 80 miles on it and I go and
I said to my mom I said I bought dad
this car why is he not driving it she
goes he does he can't drive it to work
cuz he doesn't want to have a nicer car
than his
boss so he ended up I think he sold it I
don't think he really ever drove it but
it was a it was a good fatherson thing
that we had together growing up as a kid
right yeah is pornography causing a
problem in your life it's a fair
question you know there were times when
I was looking at too much and aoul and
letting my brain be occupied with things
that it really shouldn't just things I
didn't need to see it wasn't good for my
heart wasn't good for my soul well if
that's something that's been a part of
your life at all you're certainly not
alone shame and stigma prevent men from
talking about these issues and getting
help for them
that's why I want to introduce my friend
Steve Walt who is the founder of Valor
recovery a program to help men overcome
porn abuse and sexual compulsivity their
coaches are in long-term recovery and
will be your partner mentor and
spiritual guide to transcend these
problematic behaviors I cannot uh
recommend Valor recovery enough to learn
more about Valor recovery please visit
them at Valor recovery coaching.com or
email them at admin in at Valor recovery
coaching.com and uh if it's if that's
something you struggle with um just know
that there are ways to get better blueo
baby if you need it if your wieners that
dangler baby and you want that that that
looker baby that one that's standing up
looking that's what can help you blue
Che is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra Calis and Levitra but in chabo
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
that's right blue choose tablets are
made in the USA and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discret package
the neighbors won't know they'll think
you're getting something normal some
candy or something some Lolli poop some
soda or something go to bluechew.com and
use the code Theo to receive your first
month free just pay $5 shipping that's
right Blu wants to help you have better
sex and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try blueo free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
$5 shipping that's B
cw.com promo code
tho to receive your first month free
visit blue.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Blu for sponsoring the podcast
there's so much to be thankful for
family friends food and NFL football all
week long draftking sports book is keep
keeping your Thanksgiving week full of
action new customers can bet just five
bucks on the NFL action to score
150 instantly in bonus bets that's right
no matter your appetite there's
something for you money lines parlays
props live bets and so much more you
name it they've got it I see they've got
Detroit minus 7 and a half over the
Packers on Thanksgiving Day so download
the draftking Sportsbook app now and use
code Theo new customers can bet five on
the NFL Thanksgiving action to score 150
instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking sports book an official sports
betting partner of the NFL with code
Theo the crown is yours do you remember
like the first date you ever went on
when you were a kid or something like
that oh really hockey was my life it was
huh it was your girlfriend I didn't have
one just hockey yeah just you know I had
a
um Junior a coach when I 16 years old
playing with 19 20 year olds and he
would say playing Junior Hockey really
hard um but being a professional hockey
player is a great life and so you said
you got hockey you got um uh schooling
and you got uh night life and you can
only do two of the three so make sure
you pick the right two so when you're 16
years old it was my life I loved lived
and died it go to school from 8:30 to 3
o'
practice 4 to 6 every night play usually
Thursday Saturday Sunday back to school
same things same routine when you list
when you see like how you were compared
to like how some other players were
right did you think that you almost had
like a uh abnormality how much you liked
it or how much you focused on it like
was it that kind of thing um because I
see players I have friends that are good
at things and friends that really are
let's put it this way um I know there's
a lot of other really good good players
and athletes but for us for me you know
especially when I got to be 16 I knew I
knew that was my life like I knew it
wasn't going to be a great student um I
knew it was going to be hard for me to
get a college degree I I understood that
I knew my forte was going to be hockey
and growing up playing baseball tracking
field across and I encourage parents all
the time all those Sports helped my
hockey oh yeah and so by the time I got
to 16 I was like okay this is what I'm
going to do I I want to be a
professional hockey player um and so I I
really that was my focus and the only
advice my dad used to say give me really
was um you got a great opportunity here
to really have a wonderful life and the
good Lord blessed you with a love and a
passion like I've never seen before and
sort of like don't blow it don't throw
it away and so I always kind of thought
that that I never thought I was missing
out going to a different city or going
here or doing this if I was my enjoyment
was being on the ice yeah I didn't think
I was missing anything else like wow I
never even never even phased me yeah
that was the thing and you know I can
remember
um my dad saying you know you're going
to have so many opportunities here for
some reason you know with your aunt
being down syndrome and and you growing
up with that in the Canadian Institute
for the blind was in my hometown of
Branford like there's more than just
hockey like you're going to be one day
you're going to be a symbol for good
things and so I always I kind of grew up
with it right it was that was kind of my
education what a powerful thing to say
to a child too you know that they have
the that they if they do their bet you
know not even do their best but if
they help people they make enough effort
that they have a the possibility to be a
a symbol for for good and that's really
powerful yeah and so you know I
just I that's I guess you know I became
way Gretzky and so just had a love for
it that's all is it hard like did trust
trust me there was a lot of guys with
more Talent than I had right there's a
lot of guys who were better than I was
really and then there's some guys that I
just wanted it more than yeah but by by
no means was I the best player ever
there was so many great players did any
players ever smoke cigarettes like at
halftime or whatever no it that kind of
faded out in the uh late 70s you know
60s and 70s people grew up with that
unfortunately that's what happened to my
my mother she was smoker 16 years old
but that was that era right yeah and
there was there not a lot of hockey
players who smoked but there was a few
but by 1980 that was all it was gone
some you like to romanticize seeing
somebody spark you know well I think it
was Mickey Manel or Joe deio didn't they
do ads for cigarettes in the 50s they
used to get paid to be on
pictures and everybody just kind of
accepted it and now they get mad if you
endorse um betting that's the new big
thing yeah a lot of people are doing
that now everything's kind of become
like every a lot of the ads now are
gambling I think a lot of people are
gambling on stuff and all the owners
they a lot of them own their own places
and you know all sports baseball
basketball football so you know I just
did a wonderful commercial with Jamie
Fox for B MGM and I had a ball doing it
with a wonderful guy yeah it was fun did
y'all wear tuxedos or something in we
wore suits though yeah their ads always
had like a polished look yeah it was
pretty cool he was it was his first
working day after his injury um but he
was great he was fine he was he worked
all night the night before then he
worked all night with me that night had
you ever worked with him before no no I
hadn't worked with them before but you
know small world we lived 5 minutes
apart in Thousand Oaks so I used to see
him periodically different things but he
was beloved in the community and another
guy he really didn't have any enemies
everybody loved him well he's one of the
most Talent me people forget also that
he's a standup comedian oh and how great
he was and Living Color was like the
best TV show they ever had when I was
growing up he he he the Jamie Fox show
was unbelievable he was so talented and
then he went a Oscar for I forget oh
yeah Muhammad Ali maybe no it was uh r
um Ray yeah yeah he was Unreal Ray
Leonard no who was it Ray l montine no
no the singer Ray Charles yeah I was
going blank too but he was phenomenal in
that so anyway I had fun with him he's a
wonderful guy did he seem healthy yeah
he's fine he was great he was happy um I
don't even know really what happened he
didn't you know it's not my business and
he didn't talk about it but but if you
didn't know something happened you
wouldn't even know no you wouldn't have
know he was doing fine and and like I
said said he was working late like he
had worked the night before sort of 9:00
to 5: cuz they got to shut everything
down so they can film it an actual place
right until the next night was sort of
8:00 to 5 again he was Unreal he was
fine did you guys go see a show or
anything while you were out there or no
no no I'm not big on going to shows
although my friend who I work with
Henrik lanquist went to the opening of
the sphere in Vegas wow and he said it's
not like anything you've ever seen
before first of all you two and then
so it's the future huh yeah he says they
have these AI robots that you talk to
them you think they're real
people reminds me this girl I dated for
a while I said we're going to have a a
hockey coach that'll be the first one
hockey coach AI he's our hockey
coach you know I always fantasize if it
would be pretty cool not fantasize
that's a weird word to say to another
man but I always thought about wouldn't
it be neat if there was a team where
people could sit at home and make like
as a group vote really fast on what the
next play should be and that it would
almost be a completely controlled team
by like fans you know you probably would
struggle in hockey because it's so quick
yeah but you could probably do it
football for sure set up the play um
yeah football was I think the sport that
I thought about it the most yeah hockey
be hard maybe even baseball because you
could pick the pitch that the pitcher
throws yeah and who's pitching that yeah
it'd be pretty interesting two of them
you could do probably um did you ever
get to Michael Jackson or not no but I
used to do hot yoga in Thousand Oaks uh
with his brother Tito yeah it was fun
nice nice nice guy so yeah but I never
met Michael Jackson though I remember um
I got to talked to Hulk Hogan and he met
Michael Jackson one time it was just
interesting you I got a great Hulk Hogan
story yeah so people don't know this but
Hulk used to live in Thousand Oaks too
mhm and it was it was December 24th we
go to this Thousand Oaks Mall and I'm
getting last minute Christmas gifts for
my kids who at the time sort of 10 12
and
14 so I put them all in the car and they
had a valet parking for the at at the
mall so I get come out and I put all my
bags in the car and I drive home so I
get a call around 7:00 and he goes Wayne
I go yeah and he says Terry I think his
real name was Terry Terry blea he goes
Terry
Terry he goes Hulk he goes we got a
problem I go what's the problem he goes
we got the exact same car I got your car
in your presence and you got my car my
presence so I go outside and I'm like oh
my God he goes yeah my kids are older
it's probably not going to work so I
said I'll meet you halfway so we drove
back halfway together and we switched
the cars out got the presents went home
true story you guys got in each other's
cars well cuz the valet gu just come out
and they were exact same cars and we
were you know was we weren't really
paying attention cuz it same color same
car but your kids wake up in Christmas
morning and they all get
bandanas
like they get bandanas and Body Oil
isn't that funny though your 12-year-old
daughter is getting a jar of body oil
you're like this seems a little weird
D I do remember him saying I don't think
your kids are going to like when I got
my kids they're older it's all cold they
got his kids did you uh when you met
your wife how did you know that she was
like the wife for you like dad told me
really gosh he was a real leader then
about the first week I said what do you
think he goes oh she's a lifer I go you
just met her you know what we had the
same similarities like we love we love
both want to have a family we want to
have kids um we both love sports it's
wonderful that I I actually her and I
watch hockey together baseball football
basketball she loves going to game she
loved growing up with our kids going to
all their sporting events and going to
The Girls D B ballet and dancing we just
um we think the same way I guess and
we're born 16 days apart she's January
10 I'm January uh
26 um yeah so we lot in common go you
know is it different being a dad to like
a girl and a boy like I don't have any
children like I like to have some one
day you know but I don't any some ways
it's different in other ways it's it's
not
um you know
it's just it's just a little bit
different but not really did it come
easy to you being a dad some of my
friends have a tough time and some of
them oh yeah I was I loved being a dad
so yeah you know I always told my
friends you know you do all your
parenting till about 13 or
14 um if they haven't learned by then
you haven't done the job right right
yeah and our biggest thing in our house
was everybody can say please thank you
and excuse me that was our biggest fight
not fight but that was the biggest thing
we drilled in all the time and then when
your kids get to be 16 17 18 then you
become best friends and so I don't
really look at my kids as kids anymore I
look at them as my closer friends simple
as that so oh it's interesting yeah they
kind of evolve then huh I'd rather hang
out with my kids at this age now than
travel somewhere to go visit somebody
for two days you know it's yeah just as
fun did you ever have to take your kids
like what did you ever take them
trick-or-treating or something like that
so this is a funny story too so we when
I played for the New York Rangers we had
a apartment in a w play there or no no
no um Mark massier was on that team
Brian leech so we lived in this
high-rise 16th floor right so it was our
first year in Manhattan and your whole
family is living in a highrise in
Manhattan we had a three bedroom there
was at the time we only had three kids
so we had bedroom for my wife and I one
for the two boys and one for Paulina and
so I remember I said to the dman the day
before Halloween I said where do we
trick or treat here yeah he goes oh
everybody just walks through the
building and I'm thinking no no no no so
we left on just off take them out in the
street of Brooklyn no no no listen so
I'm like we're right on Madison AB 63rd
Madison so I go out there I said okay
and I walked into every one of those
stores that I know my wife had ventured
into a lot Prada Gucci on I said you
guys better have candy tomorrow at 6:00
and so we walked the kids down m you got
to be outside right you can't be walking
so we go into like Gucci and they give
them stuff we go Prada they're getting
candy I still think they do it today but
it made more sense to me than walking
through an apartment building kids want
to be outside on Halloween oh you have
to you have to run inside yeah yeah so
always fun when you did you was it fun
doing trick- or treat when you were a
kid like do you remember what you
dressed up as you just dressed up as a
hockey player just I always went as a
hockey player so but and I'll tell you
why because every Halloween it seemed
like we had a practice that night so we
would be on the ice from like 5:00 to
6:00 and you know it gets dark by 6:30
at that time of the year in Canada so we
my dad would race me home I'd get a
pillowcase and I'd go up and down the
street get a ton of candy and that was
my and I just left my hockey uniform on
just took my helmet off and every place
I went to the people they all knew as
com as a they used to laugh cuz it's
small community small Street you knew
everybody right oh Wayne's here Wayne's
here again the hockey guy
gosh that's wild man that it was that
much of your life that it was your
Halloween costume that says a lot I feel
like yeah you know well when I was seven
I went to a barber shop and um I asked
the barber If he if he could cut my give
me a Gordy how haircut that's how much I
like the Gordy how and hockey it was
crazy what's something that you like
admire about each one of your children
kind of no I just they're all nice you
know they're polite they're not
egotistical uh they're they're not
um uh in the slightest jaded at all
they're just good kids that's you know I
my youngest two are still in college and
they love it I have a son NYU and a
daughter at SMU and three kids who have
children of their own now yeah they're
just they're nice none of them are jaded
that's the best part when you finished
uh hockey like as a um employee as a
player did you um was it did you find
like was it tough to like take that
energy and all that Mo like that cuz you
have you have such a focus and there's a
focal point was it interesting to see
like how that popped up in other places
in your life or was it that that was a
that was a big issue um it hasn't and it
doesn't wow you know I I my life was
hockey um if I go play tennis
uh I just play I'm not I don't really
even care about the score if I go play
golf it doesn't matter if I shoot 83 or
93 I don't worry about it I don't stress
about it you know I did all that you
know and I loved it um but I don't have
that same like fight or battle for fun I
just don't have that and you know people
always say Michael Jordan's so
competitive of everything he does and
that's not you that's that's not me I I
just I'm fine I'm happy with what I
accomplished I'm happy I'm I did it I'm
happy I'm done but that's all kind of
behind me now I don't worry about it
it's like uh I get parents who come up
to me you know mothers are hardest right
and my mom was worse too She chased down
Bobby Hall to get an autograph for me
and and so when moms grab me I go I get
it I get it my mom did it for me too but
the moms will always say to me will you
tell my son how many hours a day he used
to practice and I go that's not it and
she go what do you mean I go that's not
it I said I just did it cuz I love loved
it if you have to say you got to be out
there 2 hours or 3 hours you're in the
wrong thing I just was there all day
long cuz I loved it yeah wow yeah moms
would be nuts I remember Michael Landon
was coming to our town once and mom was
all excited but he didn't show
up he couldn't leave the
Prairie yeah yeah every week on that
show one of his kids was like getting
beaten by a kicked by a horse like yeah
somebody had dementia I was like what do
you mean a 9-year-old has dementia like
every every week it was like there was
like yeah there was iron in too much
iron in the water or something or
somebody was blind so when you get on
one of those early teams like did it
were you guys on a bus just cruising
like through like Canada like you guys
like just heading all over the place did
you ever have that kind of time or no um
so when I played Junior Hockey in the
league I was in Ontario M I was on a
team called Sous St Marie Greyhounds
which was the farthest north in Ontario
wow so our our closest bus trip was 3
and 1/2 hours to Sudbury so the team got
an airplane it was a DC3 no and we used
to fly to all the games and basically
played Thursday night Friday night
Saturday afternoon Sunday afternoon and
fly back to S St Marie and we do that
twice a month and then when I turned Pro
you know Edmonton we flew commercial
everywhere and you know it was a lot of
flights that we went Edmonton through
Minnesota or Edmonton through Chicago to
get
there wasn't a whole lot of direct
flights from Edmonton to Manhattan
uhuhuh so yeah we I traveled a lot we've
been around a lot I remember I went to
Florida so I was in Florida right I've
been on a cruise ship and I had to go to
Edmonton to perform right at the comedy
club there oh yeah it was like one of
the first I've been in there oh yeah in
uh at the Mall of America right or Mall
of of Canada yeah they built that one
before the one in Minnesota well that
one first of all you guys has a gun
range in it which isn't crazy you know
and we got a we got a lake with waves we
got a hockey rink in there it's pretty
much everything in there yeah yeah yeah
there's like four American Eagles in
there and there actually there was an
actual American Eagle in there last time
we were in there yeah and it was
hatching it was doing like a um I think
it had had a couple of chicklings or
whatever near Payless Shoes yeah I I've
never been a hunter you know hunting
duck hunting big in your country huh
it's big in Alberta big in saset we went
hunting one time I went one time in my
life went with three teammates we were
19 years old we didn't know what we were
doing and uh we're 2 hours in we were
duck hunting and we couldn't figure out
where the Ducks were and this guy come
over he said you guys got a goose
call that's how bad our hunting was and
we're standing there going no we just
thought there was no ducks yeah you look
over just Tony s there you got the wrong
you got the wrong horn or whatever I'm
like okay that was my last time I had to
go to this store and it was $5 to get a
permit I never even fired the gun it was
the last time I ever went never shot a g
gun since who's one of like the funniest
guys that you spend around Time Around
in the league like who's somebody that
you love being around that really makes
you laugh Brad Hall is a genius and he's
Brad Hall is one of the funniest nicest
people you ever ever meet he remembers
every word and every song he remembers
lines from movies like he's just and
he's got a big heart he's a tremendous
guy did you uh what's a good concert
that you went to that you enjoyed over
the years um you know what I'm seeing
Elton John this weekend Elton John is
phenomenal I saw Elton John and Billy
Joel together no way at the Forum years
ago which was remarkable but you know I
my very first concert I every went to
was um uh Chicago remember of the band
Chicago and I remember I was 16 years
old and I was good friends with David
Foster who was he's the producer right
producer writer he's Canadian boy and so
two years later I was playing in the
World Cup for Canada and he calls me and
he said uh there's a couple guys from
Chicago that want to come to your
practice can you get them in I'm like
yeah of course so they came in I think
the drummer's name was Johnny pazo right
and he used to play a little bit of goal
tender and hockey so they came to
practice and I'm sitting there we went
for lunch after and I remember saying 2
years ago sitting in the last row
watching their concert and two years
later I having lunch with them so I
always said that was one of my favorite
concerts oh yeah yeah I remember I got a
t-shirt I don't even know who gave I
think where we got it from I didn't even
know it was a band I thought it was just
for the city yeah that I wore when I was
a kid it was just a nice shirt it was
like pure cotton and I remember just I
remember wearing that Chicago shirt I'm
trying to think of the first concert I
ever went to might have been like
Smashing Pumpkins or something well our
big ones up there are Pink Floyd and oh
yeah the hit and tragically hip
tragically hip yeah Brian Adams and of
course oh dude I met Brian Adams in
South Africa at a breakfast
buffet um and uh he's a wonderful guy
and of course Selen Deon oh yeah she was
uh Burton Cummings was big in Canada
Burton Cummings yeah they were in a band
called The Guess Who Um I think maybe
I've heard of them I'm trying to think
of something else I've heard of um you
know I uh my mom used to make us clean
the house right
and we she would put Brian Adams on
repeat we got on like one of those CD
like you know where they mail you seven
CDs for 40 cents and then you get sued
over the years that was the first album
was Cuts Like a Knife right yeah yeah
Cuts I met him when he was 17 you met
him when he was 17 and that album had
just come out he was 17 when that came
out I was 17 was 18 he was a year or two
older than me he was that young when he
became a star oh yeah yeah and he was
good cuz from there he just got bigger
and better it's funny cuz my my friends
and all laugh at me because every time
somebody comes on whether it's a singer
or an actor or whatever I'll go you know
he's Canadian like there's so many
people that you don't know that are
Canadian that I know I go he's Canadian
you know there's so many greats Jim
Cary um hoe Mandel yeah there there's a
lot of really good Canadians are you the
most famous Wayne do you think no Wayne
Myers from Wayne's World oh yeah Wayne's
World
huh Mike Myers Wayne Newton he's he's
not Canadian though yeah oh no but just
a Wayne overall oh Bruce Wayne yeah I
didn't think of him yeah I think Batman
might have you Lil Wayne Lil Wayne I met
Lil Wayne recently at a hockey game he
was very nice and did he come up and say
I'm also Wayne like does that happen
when you're a celebrity like that like
hey I'm Wayne too or
no he just it was ver cordial just I
said hey I actually stopped him I said
can I get a picture with you he was like
of course it was at a hockey game it was
a Vegas nights game oh there you are
right there I was like I grabbed him I
was like gosh I got to get a picture of
him cuz all my kids would always say dad
you know you're in Little Wayne song I'm
like okay and so when I saw him I said
gosh I got to get a picture of him I
kind of fanned it up I kind of like
became a
mom yeah yeah became Princess Diana for
a second Lil Wayne looks a little high
in that picture too I say that I don't
blame him is there something is there
Canada doesn't rever celebrity it's
different right than in America they do
oh they do they're listen Canadians are
very proud of their country right no oh
yeah no doubt but if yeah there's
something they like the story back like
my Canadian friends love stories like
bizel M tour maner is Canadian and he
loveso like the he there's always like
yeah but this guy you know like they
love the uh well right now
probably Drake's probably are biggest
Canadian right now would he say he's
probably he's probably the he's the
closest thing right now to to Taylor
Swift I would imagine Drake or
Santa no Drake's pretty big I got to
meet Drake last weekend actually yeah at
a concert no it was um I was hanging out
with this guy David grutman he's like a
okay he's a restaurant tour I was
hanging out with this restaurant tour
guy I was in Miami and Drake had had
some uh was having like a little get
together in a bar that he rented out a
small bar and he knew it so we went by
and he and I had had messaged each other
what's that what city were you in in uh
Miami Florida okay he and I message each
other he had a concert there last week
bunch of our friends drove down for the
concert from where from Canada no no we
live in Jupiter oh you do Fort
Lauderdale area oh it's pretty over
there yeah yeah see I I got to Florida
once and I just stayed it's nice isn't
it I'm telling you I couldn't get there
as a kid but now I live there people
were on to it brother but um I got to
yeah I said hey and then we started
talking for a little bit and um it was
really nice I thought I was going to be
nervous cuz sometimes if you meet like I
think celebrities you know sometimes you
can be really nervous you know and I
just I'm glad I wasn't like real nervous
I I I get like that sometimes still is
there somebody that you met that over
the years and you were like cuz you get
surprised sometimes you're chill as
could be you're like oh I'm doing good
yeah know there's people that I've met
over the years and you go oh wow that
guy's really cool or yeah I don't know I
met President Clinton about a year ago
at the golf course and he was so nice
and yeah he like most people are pretty
nice right yeah yeah and I guess with
golf you get to probably play games with
a lot of neat people huh yeah some of
them are nice guys
um on the golf course some of them get
get competive yeah and sometimes
sometimes they don't you know yeah but
I'm not competitive so people that play
with me know I'm I'm having fun you're
just taking it
easy um what are some what like your dad
had a pretty strong religious belief did
did that carry over into your family or
what is that kind of like for you oh
yeah yeah we real strong belief you know
um when I was a kid uh I got confirmed
when I was 14 years
old um but we we have a belief of you
treat people the way you want to be
treated that's our big religion in our
house um that there's no reason to be
mean to people that's kind of what we
live
by um when you look at anything else
like in life that you want to do like
are there things that like you find now
that kind of um or when you look to your
future obviously like spending time with
your family super important do you have
any big goals still no I really don't my
wife says to me you you got to I said
you know I'm going to be 65 soon and my
goal is retirement really you know I've
traveled a lot I've done a lot I'm
loving being on TNT it's a riot great
people wonderful
organization I'm I'm thrilled doing that
a few times a month and I love it
because I'm still involved with hockey
but I don't have to stress out over
winning or losing so so when I go and
I'm doing the games people go who do you
want to win I'm like it doesn't matter
to me now my heart is obviously with
Emon La St Louis and Rangers so if
they're and I'm kind of pulling for them
but other than that I'm like whoever the
best team is hope they have a great game
oh
yeah um yeah you score kind of all your
goals I guess on the ice maybe huh there
you go um thank you so much Wayne for
your time and just for uh yeah I don't
know just being a fascinating person to
talk to and get to spend time around
it's inspiring just to hear like um that
being a human is uh just as important to
you as being a a great athlete I never
looked at myself as somebody different
we're all the same right just be nice to
people and listen I love doing your show
it's fun yeah thank you so much for your
time
brother and I feel I'm falling like
these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of mind I
found I can feel it in my
bones it's going
to